if you can describe your energy as a day
I think it's definitely spring it's 73
degrees I love that degree Fahrenheit by
the way low gloomy but the Sun comes out
a little later
it's definitely spring in that kind of
day I gotta do oh hey didn't see you
there
hello GQ my name is Steve Lacey and this
is my essentials so this here is one of
my favorites it's a Steve Lacey as you
can see you there
look custom joint and this is what keeps
me sane that's one of my favorite colors
it looks very old and it has like 65
hardware I'm nerding out right now I'm
sorry but it has the neck of like the
newer models I love so it plays like
[Music]
alright that's not it's like my birthday
and my signature this is me that's a
guitar May 23rd Gemini every new guitar
player you know it wants a Fender Strat
but they're kind of expensive I start
off with the fake one which is a squire
strap to have my own custom one is you
know it's kind of nice well I have
several others so I wouldn't be too
pissed
these are proud of loafers these shoes
have been to the moon and back there are
about 850 or something like that that's
the price you gotta pay for a good lover
it's just the perfect low for the
thickness of this soul here
and how it gets thinner to go through
the hits just it's just amazing the
roundness and the squareness at the same
time but not too square nor round I
could go on for days about these shoes
as you can see I've beat these to the
ground look at that's great I guess
maybe when I was younger than that oh I
got a stay now I'm like give me all the
dirt give me all the scrapes I love it
do that some people buy shoes like this
I really did this I just wear them
everywhere I go jogging
I'm just gonna imagine I wear these to
the airport
I wasn't everyday with every outfit
actually I wore these on my album cover
maybe one day I'll like auction them or
they'll be like in a museum these would
be very famous look at that let me know
you can find a cheaper one that's as
good as this I'll buy all of them I mean
not like Nike comes over like to wear
every day is like sustainable yeah oh
it's like move chocolate mousse this is
hand sanitizer from that like little bag
you get when you get flown out a little
like Delta one bag you know you find
first class next time you travel for
somebody tell them you only can go at
this first class you get a bag your hand
sanitizer like some socks a little eye
thing a little toothbrush they take care
you touch a lot of things and things be
dirty you might be eating some chips and
you might wanna you know get the left
and it's all the germs recyclable right
there but with this you can do that
freely you touch doorknobs shopping
carts bathroom doors all kinds of things
you need this looking that's how Jeremy
it is I just been touching clothes
there's bad bacteria and good bacteria
that's on your hands if you use this too
often you wash off all the bacteria
including the good stuff so you can't
use it often class dismissed
wash your hands this custom Apollo 21
earbuds thanks Apple earbuds without a
wire it's kind of nice they're really
good for like just a random walk out
this specific pair is from my album
listening party where he has a silent
disco
like 50 pair for everyone everyone was
like listening on their own and dancing
in their own little zone it was really
nice you can't really talk I think it
could be revolutionary once they figure
out the latency problem because you
can't make beats with wireless earphones
it's a delay if I'm on a plane and I
have on like Bluetooth earphones and I'm
like a beat on my iPad right now I would
have to pull out earphones with wires
because I'll press you know a key right
and it will come maybe like a couple of
milliseconds after rather than like you
know real-time so I think once they
figure out that then it could be
revolutionary right now it's just cute
if I'm dancing it has to be like over
120 because I think I look hot doing
just a nice hand Bob it's my [ __ ] to
staff had bought am a raver boy this is
where I talk about cleanliness this is a
tide stick as you can see I've had it
for a while
it's a good thing to carry around and
especially speaking to you GQ we're
talking about clothes here clothes
clothes get dirty it's to really the
tomato sauce that got down tomato sauce
I think Thai sticks are really just for
tomato sauce I think that's really the
only stain that I get often it's tomato
sauce spaghetti I went to Rome for the
first time in have spaghetti and I have
to say that's my favorite place to use
to forget E I'm talking like hotel room
service better than any spaghetti I've
ever had like simple spaghetti like no
bolognese just pure and noodles tomato
sauce hotel room service Wow and you
know you're traveling right and you're
in that section of like that that's
small though stuff together what do I
need yeah see the Thai stick I'm like oh
[ __ ] that can that can be pretty handy
what do you know I mean I don't think
there's any any left to be quite honest
with you yes dried up how to use it
it's done he says kills nits lip-balm I
was in there getting something face
washing I realized I'd have any
chapstick on me
gonna go ahead and use this right now
show you how he century to his in real
time my lips began - you sometimes I
can't be walking around like that that's
important I can't be caught slipping you
know it's okay to do better cuz it's all
I have right now so see Centro until I
find the next best one sometimes I
forget and I'm like my stage and I feel
like my lips are actually the whole time
I can just feel the dryness I'm gonna
stage and playing guitar I gotta hold it
down I can't just like run off and go
get my chapstick it's a hard place to be
I live a hard life now I make sure this
stays in my pocket when I'm performing
alright I just applied a whole bunch
before I go home oh yes I love this one
this is a good one I don't know how long
ago these came out but the Thunderbolt
Chargers I encourage you if your Apple
phone user get you one of these fast
sometimes I'll just be roaming the mall
the Apple Store is always a good one to
go into it just funds looks great I
needed a phone charger I saw this was
like I'll try that okay I know USBC is
faster tried it out and it's a great
charge amazing charge
I said Romo mall Roman is like a walk in
New York the big mall you thought
earphones is it's a fun time the mall is
great oh [ __ ]
okay don't reveal my location actually
hahahaha the block will be hot and I
can't go there anymore with just a food
court you just walk around and it kind
of reminds me of like eighth grade like
no school I was the hangout you know I
still just say true that like a mall
lifestyle though I don't shop there
that's Trevor one store actually you
need clothes all the time
thank you it's the USBC plug it's not
the regular USB I think it's like twice
or three times faster it's beautiful you
can go from like 20 percent to 80 and
I'm in fact here you can test it right
now this is a Balenciaga bag oh says you
are the world I just like the size of it
and I think is very cute and a nice
message for someone to see even me
sometimes you are the world it's funny
but kind of deep at the same time if you
want it to be it's however you interpret
it really it's like I'm running errands
you know just like on this side right
here but if I'm like at a party I want
to secure it a little more so I'll do
this even though this looks more
annoying I just like to do that for
security just I like to carry it this is
just a perfect size for like your day
bag and I can fit a lot of things and my
wallet fits right here it's cute yeah I
love balloons yoga a inhaler a bureau
well I mean I'd die without it I think I
think it's only like for certain things
I'm doing too much if I drink I think
I'm kind of allergic to alcohol if I
have like a cup of wine by the end of it
I'm like in my cheeks are red so that's
when I need this someone told me it's
Asian flush because I'm half Filipino
dude does that happen to you or no so
maybe someone lied to me and I'm just
like allergic to alcohol what are you
laughing at me I'm not a joke if you
noticed I do really well with like
letting things go I've lost some [ __ ]
and your own things you can't lose it's
great if you catch my drift
thank you so much for watching this has
been my essentials oh [ __ ] I'm sorry